après une élection qui attend diviser le
pays
justin trudeau a maintenant le devoir de
rassembler je suis persuadé qu'en
travaillant de concert
rien n'est impossible l'unité nationale
et placé à l'avant scène grâce au
dialogue et à la coop coopération tous
les régions toutes les régions du pays
peuvent surmonter les défis
d'aujourd'hui le gouvernement promet un
appui indéfectible aux travailleurs du
secteur des ressources naturelles dans
l'ouest et de développer de nouveaux
marchés mais avec un gouvernement
minoritaire
les libéraux se doivent aussi de tendre
la main aux autres partis réduira les
formalités administratives pour qu'il
soit plus facile de créer et de faire
croître une entreprise de démarrage ou
une petite entreprise pour les
conservateurs une réduction de la
paperasserie pour les entreprises
pour le bloc la promesse d'indemnité
pleine et entière pour les producteurs
laitiers et pour le npd
la mise sur pied d'un système national
d'assurance médicaments les libéraux
démontre même de l'ouverture aux idées
qui figurait dans le programme des
autres partis des idées comme les soins
de dents dentaire universel mérite
d'être étudiée et j'encourage le
parlement à le faire
[Musique]
l'occasion aussi de réitérer les grandes
promesses libérales mettre en oeuvre la
déclaration des nations unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones dans la
première année du mandat maintenir la
taxe sur le carbone baisser les impôts
ou interdire les armes d'assaut mais
pour certains engagements
les moyens et les échéances demeurent
floues comme la réforme fiscale visant
les géants du web
le gouvernement veut revoir les règles
qui encadrent le nouvel environnement
numérique de manière à ce qu'elle soit
équitable pour tout le monde cet appel à
la collaboration n'est pas bien reçu par
l'opposition
le npd et les conservateurs semblent
indiquer qu'ils vont voter contre le
discours
nous sommes déçus alors je dois était
une opportunité de signaler aux
canadiens changer direction c'est clair
que ce n'est pas suffisant pour régler
les problèmes que les gens font face en
matière des crises climatiques encore
des belles promesses les 100 des actions
concrètes pour ce premier vote de
confiance c'est le bloc québécois qui
devrait sauver le gouvernement en votant
pour
malgré des passages jugés vague alors je
vais prendre des poignets ça ne donne
pour nos aînés je vais prendre les
poignets que ça ne donne pour nos
agriculteurs
si le premier mandat de justin trudeau
s'était ouvert sous le thème du
changement
le second reposera en grande partie sur
le compromis aussi difficile soit il a
trouvé ici louis blouin radio canada
ottawa